We, as a society, are eating twice as much meat...
...as we did in the 50s.
So what was once the special little side treat...
...now is the main, much more regular.
So really, any of these angles should have been enough...
...to convince me to go vegetarian.
And there I was, tucking into a big, old steak.
So why was I stalling?
I realized that what I was being pitched was a binary solution.
It was either you're a meat eater or you're a vegetarian.
And I guess I just wasn't quite ready.
Imagine your last hamburger.
So my common sense, my good intentions,...
...were in conflict with my taste buds...
...and I'd commit to doing it later.
And not surprisingly, later never came.
Sound familiar?